when James T Laney stepped down as Emory
University's president he was leaving an
institution of higher learning better
off than when he found it
dr. Lanie's leadership helped propel
Emory from a regional teaching
institution to a major national research
university all within a brief span of 16
years his energy and vision succeeded in
attracting more students faculty
academic departments and funding to the
University he came to love he convinced
President Jimmy Carter to join Emory's
faculty and his friendship with Coca
Cola's president Robert Woodruff was
instrumental in the donation of 105
million dollars to the University the
largest single gift ever to any
institution at that time unbalanced dr.
Lanie's philosophy and practice of what
he termed education of the heart stamped
an indelible mark on Emory that is still
evident he cultivated that philosophy at
Yale where he took four separate degrees
and honed it during his term as dean of
Emory's Candler School of Theology it
was during dr. Lanie's tenure that
Candler was ranked among the top 10
theological colleges in North America
after stepping down as president of
Emory University dr. Laney was appointed
US ambassador to South Korea it was a
homecoming of sorts as a United
Methodist minister dr. Laney had once
served there as a missionary dr. Gary
Hawk of Emory University spoke with dr.
Laney in January 2005
you
when you got to Candler then in 1969 you
must have had clearly some some goals
some intentions what what specifically
did you have in mind in terms of shaping
theological education through Candler
and and how did you set about trying to
arrange those goals remove the faculty
for them well first of all I was very
deeply committed to contextual education
in a sense a modern counterpart would be
service learning the the sense in which
you are put into a situation was
vicariously at Harvard and other law
schools and Business School with the
case study but in this instance you
really enter the situation itself with
all of the emotional and and other
overtones but understood careful
supervision not only of the person who
is an expert in it in one case a
clinical pastoral education a hospital
or this institution similar to that or
an urban setting I was in I was very
much interested in getting the pastoral
students into more than just the
hospitals I wanted them to understand
the urban problems race problem problem
with poverty and health care and that
sort of thing and so we set up a series
of practicums you might say in which all
the students who were in the pastoral
program the ministerial program had to
take one full semester or its equivalent
in one the CPE where they learn to be in
supervision and then the next year in an
urban setting and then finally we did it
in terms of the church itself
identifying churches that we thought
modeled good ministry and care for the
parishioners and the role in the
community but the unique thing about it
that was doing it that
intensively was probably somewhat of a
pioneering effort at that time although
now I think it's pretty commonplace the
thing that was really unique was
insisting that the faculty themselves
participate in this move out of the
classroom oh this this has some very
interesting reverberations and I was
enormous ly helped in this by Charles
gherkin whom I recruited from Grady
Hospital I was very impressed with him
and brought him out as a member of the
faculty teaching but also who would
oversee the the whole program and meet
once a month with a faculty who were
participating what what this meant was
if there were 12 supervisors who were
professionals there were 12 faculty
paired with those things each of those
who each had 15 students or whatever and
the faculty were expected to reflect
theologically in behalf of the students
was it turned out in behalf of
themselves and gherkin was a master that
helping shape the faculty and overcome
their resistance which we would all have
I mean this is not a criticism it's just
natural
so that out of that we not only got more
closely aligned with the students and
their struggles but also the faculty
themselves were beginning to forge a
community because they were sharing all
of we're sharing something in common but
I think that was the most important
thing that we did because it had an
impact on the student body it also
created community with the faculty and a
bond with the students and I
participated myself so I know what it
was lying and it meant a great deal to
me
there were several other aspects to the
opportunities that Canada provided one
was at that time the ministerial
education fund of the Methodist Church
which had actually begun out of the old
one and two percent plan that Henry
Bowden and Buster Byrd and DW Brooks had
started back in the 50s with Dean
Trimble had now gone nationwide was
beginning to move into high gear and
that was providing significant funding
for the Methodist seminaries and Candler
was getting about almost a million
dollars a year which was a lot of money
at that time
so I persuaded President Atwood to let
Canela be a table on its own bottom i I
just thought we could do it and this was
a relief to him because Candler had been
subsidized by a substantial amount every
year by the general university funds so
we were able not only to that gave a lot
of freedom in terms of how much new
faculty we could add as long as we could
pay for it and we could carry over our
balances at the end of the year which
had not been done before when they
didn't ever had about us so we could
build up a reserve in other words so
within the first three or four years we
added twelve net faculty to two of
faculty that at the room that was almost
a 50 percent increase and these were all
bright young faculty was a huge change
in theological education is a small
universe and that caused a lot of waves
around the country that Canada was doing
all this you know
you
and then that
everything was came a little later was
the opportunity to purchase the Hartford
seminary library which catapulted us
from nowhere to number two in the
country and among theological libraries
and really was a marvelous addition not
just in terms of numbers but in terms of
quality and range and that sort of thing
so all of that began was a sort of a
yeasty mix that kept everything bubbly I
remember about the fourth year I was
there somebody said there's a new
ranking out among the theological
schools and and canlib was ranked wait
you know Cantor never been ranked
anywhere and he was ranked way up I
don't know tied with Princeton or
something and you know up in the top
pantheon of the top half-dozen or
something and all of a sudden you know
there was new it was a bracing
realization I look back upon those eight
years as being as productive and as
happy as any I've ever had
the theology school really had risen in
stature nationally and in its ranking
let's say and the Graduate division of
religion began its upward in many ways
the the pockets of religious study
throughout the university were
academically at the fore and yet 1976
Sanford Atwood announces that the
following year he's going to retire as
president and you come to the floor as
the candidate for the presidency I
imagine that there were some skeptics
around the university no skeptics about
the prospect of having this research
university led by a Methodist minister
the Dean of the theology school what
what was let me ask you first of all
what what it was that led you to
consider moving from the deanship of the
theology school to leadership of the
university and then how did how did you
address the skeptics out there well I
don't know how address the skeptics
except by action but part of it was the
growing confidence that what we were
doing was wasn't appropriate so we're
setting the pace for the university I
mean obviously disciplines very and
schools have the curriculum all that but
the ideas of what made for outstanding
educational experience I think were
valid in themselves
I had broadly khaki from Vanderbilt in
72 I think to head up the Graduate
Division he went on seven years later to
become Dean at Yale and then in 1974
Christa Stendhal who was been in Harvard
invited me to come up as a visiting
professor I had a leave coming which had
already been approved by the president
and so forth so we went up there and it
turned out very quickly that what they
were doing was looking me over for the
past
of his successor and I taught a seminar
there and you know realized and I was
interviewed by trustees and of course
got to know Derek marcano I realize you
know that what we were doing at Emory
was was of that wasn't that measure I
mean I didn't we didn't have anything to
apologize for I mean Emory was very good
and there was a kind of a new confidence
built on the fact that I had already
served while I was Dean on the visiting
committee to oversee the Yale religious
life and Divinity School I served on the
committee I won chairman and was
confident you know what we were doing
was was you know it was good it didn't
then no apology to anybody and it didn't
take second place to either Harbor to
Yale well with that kind of confidence
and the fact that because Henry bound
and some of the other trustees knew that
Harvard was looking at me
they already when I came back in 75
began saying well you know we'd like for
you to consider the possibility of being
president now there's a lot to go
through and all and very the integrity
of the process but they they want they
want to be not to leave and I was
comfortable with that because I felt
that if it should work out that way and
I knew a number of the trustees that you
know we would have a team and we'd have
the trust at least a handful of the
trustees backing it and I had the
confidence then that what we were doing
could be drawn on a larger canvas I
don't mean everything but the general
idea is the direction University and so
I think out of that and the kind of
entrepreneurship that was
involved with the Hartford seminary
purchase which by the way got a whole
page in the New York Times on the second
section or something back then which
they said was the largest transfer of
books in American history which we loved
all that you know and so out of that
grew the the thought that if it if the
bid should come to me I certainly would
not be averse to taking it you know I
really you know once something that I
had consciously sought that I can say
that but as it kind of evolved the like
as the likelihood of it increased or the
prospects my confidence that it would
not be inappropriate all seemed to
correspondingly increase I think that's
the only way I say it you know I didn't
I didn't feel it all intimidated by the
thought of working in the whole
university as opposed to just a theology
school
you
you mentioned the Hartford book
collection purchase which certainly was
a bold move and I think the beginning of
your presidency really is a series of
bold steps it may not have felt like
that at the time but just shortly after
you became president you and the Board
agreed to launch a major fundraising
drive I think when you became president
you announced that some of your
ambitions included raising the level of
scholarship funding professorship and or
so on and clearly you also had a vision
for enhancing campus life and student
life but it was really in 1979 the
announcement of the hundred and five
million dollar Woodruff fund transfer to
Emory that came as a blockbuster piece
of news and was was really a bold bold
step before the university garnered
national attention as the largest gift
to higher education in American history
up to that point say a little bit about
what led to that gift and how that was
nurtured and and what some of the
thinking was behind that both in terms
of the university administration and the
trustees of the fund well I think to
answer that I'd want to say first of all
that within three months of my zooming
office as president I did lay before the
trustees a whole list of things that I
wanted to try to accomplish and I looked
back on and I you know I haven't want to
be careful this is not said in a
patronizing way but I really saw myself
as an educator in every sense of that
word my role was to articulate and
educate the trustees that is you know to
help them understand what what we were
about and if they will if the goals were
worthy to get their support educate the
faculty as to what we were trying to
accomplish together in addition to their
own work and
and course to educate the students and
how do we do that most successfully and
so constant it was always on my mind to
try to articulate to try to set forth
constantly what we're about and why and
why it's important and how we might get
there and of course and to get there
that means enlisting support so in that
sense it was an act of persuasion
nothing but rhetoric I learned this way
back in the rhetoric of touching the
common cords of response the people
shared and then building on that you
know so in a way you develop confidence
and trust and you move forward I think
that trustees were a little they sort of
caught their breath when I laid out when
I thought we needed to do and begin and
look put a price tag on because it was
really very aggressive for Emory at that
time and you know they're always there's
a question of well do you really need
this I mean know these ambitions or you
know these real are these just personal
sort of things you know and you know you
you you have to they have to buy into
the vision that this is not only what
should be done but it can be done and
that if in doing it we really will
accomplish something that's worthwhile
you know we're not just going to keep
along with the status quo and that's on
me
so I'll set that for
you
now the interesting thing is that mr.
Woodroof won on the board so I had to go
over to see him a lot to keep him up and
up-to-date with what was going on back
here and in those meetings I wanted to
share with him what we were about and we
had some interesting talks and
particularly the time when he said he
didn't didn't believe it endowment we
were trying to raise a lot of money for
endowment well it turns out that was
based on his thought that the endowment
was idle capital and it took me about
two three weeks to figure out idle
capital will the opposite of idle
capital is working Cavanaugh that is a
term that they use in business is
working capital so we we simply
transliterated endowment into working
capital and he bought it something that
was fine but once he signed on that
wasn't a question of what he was doing
but he had to begin to get a sense of
the enthusiasm and himself participate
in this in the positive spirit they won
and so that that was a took a while of
course it was two years and something
after I became president for without the
gift
you
and I remember one
the things that Jimmy Sibley and I
talked about very early on and Jimmy
Williams was maybe we can get the
trustees of the fund to raise the payout
to Emory from 40 to 60% which would be a
big in you know a lot if the pun was
worth over 100 million Oh that'd be
equivalent of 20 million-dollar the
income from 20 million dollars but in
the process the thought of that and
thought that George Woodruff that he and
Robert were going to die you know in a
not too distant future led them
particularly George to say why don't we
just turn the whole thing over to Emory
I mean the corpus well the difference
between receiving a portion of the
income and getting the whole corpus is
enormous because of course the growth of
the corpus over the next 15 years was
just unbelievable
I mean the hunt those 3 million shares
of cocolate were transferred to us the
market value today would be way over 2
billion dollars I mean if you want to
say wow what would a gift comparable to
that make a splash today well 2 billion
dollars would do it but that was big
money and anyway George took appropriate
pride in George Woodruff in sort of
helping mr. Woodruff of course had to be
enthusiastic about it you know it
wouldn't have happened without his
say-so because he was the dominant
brother
you
the gift came without restriction that
is on its use and how although they said
it we'd like for it to be endowment they
didn't even I don't think it was any
restriction on that it was and it was
for the University and that was a
godsend because then without you know we
could begin to make plans for the whole
university not not slighting Madison but
putting it in perspective you know in
the total picture
you
the other thing that happened about that
time was the the growing conviction that
we ought to try to sequester the
Woodruff fund from the general endowment
the idea of sequestering the thing was
that we wanted to see if we couldn't
continue the the power of initiative
within the university and once it gets
built in to the budget an income stream
it its power is there but it has no no
an additional impetus into the budget or
into the programs and we succeeded in in
persuading the trustees either they won
hard to persuade them because they
always liked to be conservative but it
was a hard role for the faculty and some
of the faculty were extraordinarily
critical of the first few years of our
use of the fund because they didn't see
the immediate results in fact some rode
in the wheel that they thought that I
somehow was had some sort of chicanery
wasn't incredible but in any case in the
first working out of this since we had
set up scholarships and wooded
professorships and special project like
that as being the first call on it was a
need for a huge infusion in the Emory
collagen and scholarships we just it's
hard to believe what the scholarship
budget was when I took over I think it
was less than a million dollars for the
whole college we were just so heavily
tuition dependent you know and that
constrains us d Norma's Lee and David
mentor who was in the deans him and he
said we need 20 million dollars 20
million dollars no I don't remember what
we finally wound up with but it was a
substantial amount but we agreed that we
would start off the first year with that
amount
and the next year we would read well it
would grow and then we'd back out they'd
grow year by year we you know and come
in with the freshmen and so forth but
then after four years we'd begin to back
it out and we did and the college put it
had built gradually built it into their
budget well the point of all this was to
try to leave at least 50% of they would
have fun free and unencumbered so that
we could do matching things and pull
back and so forth and I think that
worked for a long time I know that I
think probably by now it's long since
been been fed into the budget but that
enable for at least 15 years to start
initiatives they were just invaluable I
mean we could just simply do things
you
the extraordinarily fortunate and being
able to become friends with mr. Woodruff
we spent a lot of time together and the
more time I spent with him the higher my
opinion of him as a human being was he
he had the most ineffable smile I've
ever seen on a man he didn't always
smile but when he did it was absolutely
winsome and I could see why as a younger
man he was so successful and whatever he
did because he just had this marvelous
innocence charisma in that sense not
rhetorically but personality was
you
and I remember once on his birthday was
in December the six thing and the first
year I was president I was racking my
brain to think what can I give mr.
Woodruff for a birthday present and
Alistair Cooke had come to the campus in
October to deliver the Robert Jones
lecture the Bobby Jones lecture and when
he the next week when he gave his weekly
voice from America he spent the whole
time talking about Emory hmm and he
raved about Emory and he said it was the
most beautiful campus he had been on
Americanism far better than Berkeley or
Princeton or apotema
and so I through some friends I got hold
of that tape and took it down to issue a
where mr. Woodruff always celebrated his
birthday down at his plantation I was it
was absolutely unheard of to say that
you wanted to come home mr. Woodruff
birthday and invite yourself but I did
and they said you can come in through a
clock ya know stay for dinner okay so I
took a tape recorder and played it for
him the alistair cooke thing where he
was so violent and I left and from then
on I got an invitation on my own to come
for the birthday every year down there
the way and we had a good time you know
hunting was included in that but it was
we shared a lot and you know I looked
upon him in a way as a kind of a father
figure he was a lovely human being and
he was always interested and what we
were doing at Emory he wanted me to tell
him all we were doing I don't mean the
minutia but the big things and he was so
proud of it
you
and after this is an influence good
story after we the Woodruff gift had
been announced it was on the front page
of New York to him home he he said
doctor he never called me Jim
dr. Lainey do you do you know how much
money buck Duke gave to Trinity College
and I said I've heard it was 40 million
dollars mr. Woodruff he said and how did
they show their appreciation I said you
know they changed the name of Trinity
College to Duke University
he took his second book and I said I
think that was appropriate don't you
mister wouldn't yeah I do and you know
what your gift is the largest it even
beat that gift
he smiled they said yeah and that was
the end of the conversation
I was I was so afraid he was gonna ask
me directly but he never did and he
never seemed to bother him and all that
we didn't change the name of the
University
you
let me turn to something that that
really was a kind of coup one among many
in your presidency after President
Carter's defeat for re-election in 1980
he was offered I think a number of
possibilities to affiliate with various
universities but he ended up joining the
faculty at Emory and beginning a
collaboration with the university that
has been rich and varied over the last
two and a half decades how how did you
recruit a former president in the United
States to the Emory faculty what went
into that just went open eyes can become
no it really began with Hamilton Jordan
coming to approaching me our son Tom was
working as a theological student intern
in Washington at the White House he got
that on his own not through me because I
didn't really know President Carter that
well and I'm and and Tom our son Tom
knew Hamilton and Hamilton wanted to see
me and he said I'm leaving the
administration regardless of the
election and I'd like to come and spend
a semester or a year at Emory as a
visiting scholar or something like that
I want to write a book so we work that
out but in the process we had some talks
about what if what if President Carter
didn't win and so when that Santa
virtuality occurred I was prepared to
talk with President Carter and had an
access to and through Hamilton Jordan we
got along well we share a lot of the
same thing we have Southern roots
we're both religious you know we both
tend to be more alive more moralistic
and you know the things that he talked
about wanting to do other things that I
thought would be good for him he to be
allied with and certainly the for him to
be on the faculty and all so one thing
led to another and we partly our
friendship developed into a partnership
but I read
didn't although we had been to the wine
now several times we were with a large
group and it did not indicate anything
while he was president I was I was not
close to him but we developed the
friendship later and I think the quality
of the Carter centers work and its
success as a testimony to the validity
of his establishing the center and of
our association with him
you
I'm going to come back to something you
said earlier about power of persuasion
and the art of rhetoric and the
importance of rhetoric and language to
the presidency and the university or to
any leadership position one of the
phrases that people appropriately
associate with your presidency is the
phrase the education of the heart this
was the title of an address you gave at
Harvard and it was later the title of a
collection of your speech as an essays
and I'm curious about how you arrived at
that phrase how you came to that not
just that phrase but to that concept as
a kind of guiding emphasis of your
leadership well really this was a
formulation that kind of grew out of
this idea of education as formation I my
own education at Yale particularly in
the Divinity School and my two-year
stint as chaplain and as English teacher
at joke school a boarding school in
Connecticut convinced me of the age
age-old business going back to Plato one
of the importance of formation education
is not merely theoretical it's it's the
total person and that values are
inherent in what's going on and what's
important how we choose this and that
and what attracts us and what repels us
all that's part of it is simply a matter
of explicate event and trying to the
desiccation of higher education because
of the excessive specialization and the
pressures on the faculty to be
accountable to their disciplines
nationally and their professional
organizations rather than either to
their own institution or their students
that that tension that they live with
this is not a criticism the faculty that
is life as we see it today nevertheless
tended unless there was a countervailing
force then it would pull the faculty
weigh-in and there they felt that their
assessment in their work was primarily
by their peers and that's very important
part of the quality but also an
important thing is the the dynamics of
the classroom and the interaction of
faculty and students and I over and over
again I'm impressed when some of the
finest faculty and the most
distinguished scholars speak of how some
of their best insights come from
seminars with undergraduates because
there's a free-flowing kind of
interaction and that scholarship and so
forth
not just the pursuit of a laser-like
thing but but that freshness and
impromptu quality and it was that aspect
in formation and how people really you
know while we might back away from in
local parentis the fact is that faculty
have a huge influence on house to what
students think and how they feel their
their view of life I mean they really
want a size that they want to find a
student they don't want to be told and
they don't certainly don't want it
imposed and make it a requirement but
they are constantly taking their cue
from faculty and from mentors that's the
whole point of what a mentor means it's
not just what you've learned from them
consciously but all that and then and
you know and the issue of in law and in
medicine and other thing of
apprenticeship and an internship no
that's only carries with it that kind of
weight and in the so it has to do with
judgment as well as knowledge that comes
out of this kind of education and I
don't know where the phrase came from
Gary but I think in it was an evolution
a series of speeches that I developed
talking the teachers actually and then
Harvard asked me to speak to the
National Association of alumni heads and
so I gave that speech and the the editor
of the Harvard magazine was there he
said that is so radical radical
well yeah played those radical and and
Rousseau is radical you know all the
great philosophers of education you know
I think back of my own education and
this this is where I got it is it's
hardly novel but in many ways it guided
I would imagine you're thinking about
campus life programs it was certainly
the contextual education that you spoke
about all of that and my desire to get a
better campus life experience for
students was was part and partly this
wasn't just indulging the students it
was really an attempt to make more
conscious and a given more positive spin
to how they experienced and the extra
critical act that all the things that go
on on campus that are part of the
education you know and it was that and
anyway the Harvard magazine published
this speech was supposed to shock and
all that for the Harvard audience now
Harvard faculty are they read it in yawn
you
I thought I would ask you for some
impressions or memories of the Emory
leaders and benefactors and great lights
that you encountered during your time as
president henry Bowden senior chairman
of the board of trustees when you know
Henry was suah generous he was uniquely
Emery beloved by Emery and unqualified
love for Emery
he and his generation of Emery graduates
back in the 30s ran the university for a
long time he and Paula termen and both
Leigh Jones and of course Jake Ward and
a whole bunch of others were involved in
that Henry was really the one who
recruited me for president I wouldn't be
president I wouldn't have been president
if he hadn't been for Henry he had he
believed in me and thinking despite the
fact that I was a Methodist minister and
feel but in any case Henry just knew
everybody and everything and of course
he was a great Rock or a contour and
that made a minute meant that you know
he could always give a speech at the
drop of a hat and he was like the Pied
Piper and I learned so much from Henry
you know how to deal with people in a
gracious way and not simply a hectoring
way this is a tendency of Ministers you
know but anyway Henry was such a
remarkable person you know there are a
lot of people like in there who really
have loved Emery in the long wind in a
way I realized that I was an outsider
who came in and I had to learn to love
the see Emery from their standpoint and
not just the Emery that I thought it
ought to become and the combination of
those two is a powerful thing
you
let me ask you about a faculty member
that's legendary now passed from the
scene
George Pathan Oh George call him my
beloved curmudgeon George and I got
acquainted when burden on our children
were in Oxford when I was Dean at the
theology school in Oxford England he was
over there on leave and we were there
for a term and we just got acquainted we
had to saw each other a lot and became
real good friends I think up and done
that time the last thing he would have
ever wanted was the thought of a
Methodist minister being president of
Emory but I think after that we became
friends and it was not if it was not
something he endorsed it was something
that at least he could live with but I
of course he was the what do you call it
the not the beetle but the chief
Marshall chief Marshall right and he
took great pride in that and he helped
me design my president's robe and we had
a great time we we would often disagree
and it was a wonderful disagreement
because we we could really snarl at each
other and never mean it
you
one of the first Woodruff professors
you've recruited was Richard Elmen big
Ullman was a lovely human being and a
marvelous scholar at that time was the
Goldsmith's professor of English
Literature at Oxford and we were able to
get him to spend half of a year here
every year as would a professor
Elmen and his wife Mary were marvelous
addition and they I think they raised
the visibility memory across the
Atlantic by choosing to come here and he
was such a gracious soul that instead of
being seen as an outsider and a sort of
you know snob or something coming in
from fancy places he quickly became a
real colleague of the not just of
English but of Art in Arts and Sciences
and I think did more to allay the
anxieties or uneasiness or standoffish
mossad the faculty about these new
appointments because he was so fine so
CV and he and I became really good
friends and we visited him in Oxford and
all I might add as a as a footnote they
used to live at Clifton towers when they
stated when they were at Emory which is
not far from wall water and at that time
our paper was delivered on Clifton Road
at the mailbox which is a half a mile
from the house and I'd look out in the
morning and here would be Nicky Ullman
and what I called his fast trudge this
was jogging but it was hardly John and
he would drop the paper an hour and our
doorstep and keep going around the
circle and although
whoever had a more sublime paper with
paper boy that's great
you
Pollard Turman from the determine the
other national senators name Pollard
Pollard was one of those along with
Henry Benton he was willing to do
anything for him me and when we were
without a Development Officer very early
in my presidency he became the acting
device president for development which
means is it meant his office at that
time was down the hall and he became a
very dear and trusted advisor me
invaluable Pollard was one of the people
who could interpret what we were trying
to do to the trustees in a gracious way
Pollard ranks up there with with the top
memory graduates just a superb human
being I spoke at his funeral and I
remember I thought Pollard is everyone's
best friend everybody who knows him
thinks that Pollard is his best friend
that's him he was burnt always said he's
he is the best gentlemen I've ever met
you
you must it seems to me think from time
to time about your legacy and what you
were able to do with your colleagues at
Emory and how how does one just to take
it out of the personal realm how does
one reflect on that legacy a decade
after the fact and and how does one hope
for the future and and what comes after
how do you how do you reflect on what
you were able to do and and what you
hope still can be done as a result of
that well first of all I don't have any
concerns institutionally about Emory
Emory is flourishing beyond far beyond
anything I could have imagined when I
was here I my confidence in what we were
trying to do in terms of the spirit of
Emory and the educational philosophy is
so fundamental that is my confidence
that it is so necessary and right in
timely and I'm pleased at Emory is
carrying that on I don't want to call it
a legacy my interest is in how that the
spirit of education really informs this
nation I mean I guess my time in Korea
in government has given me a sense of
the nation I don't want to sound
grandiose at all but I really
those are my greatest concerns what who
are we as a people what are we doing and
how does education fit into that and
just to be the mostest and the best
disis is really it's shallow it's very
shallow and I think education has as its
primary purpose the deepening of these
things you know the fundamental
questions about life and what we're what
we're about and what were why we're
doing things and to raise these not in
the sense of trying to depreciate all
them
Arius activities of humankind but rather
to make sure that there's certain focal
points that that that's what I'm
concerned about and that's when I
continue to speak about and work for and
I'm proud of his role in that